Dunkle Materie und Dunkle Energie sind uns
trotz intensiver Forschungsarbeit immer noch
ein riesiges Rätsel.
Doch jetzt ist japanischen Wissenschaftlern
ein vielleicht entscheidender Schritt gelungen:
Mit Hilfe eines exotischen Teilchens haben
die Fachleute eine überraschend stabile Form
neuer Materie kreiert.
Ein wirklich spannendes Experiment!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es jeden
Tag ein neues Science-Video- Abonniert den
Kanal, dann und nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Herzlich willkommen!
Obwohl die Existenz der Dunklen Materie bereits
vor 80 Jahren vorhergesagt wurde, gehört
ihre Zusammensetzung wohl weiterhin zu den
wichtigsten ungeklärten Fragen der Physik
und Kosmologie.
Wir haben es hier also quasi mit dem “Heiligen
Gral” der modernen Naturwissenschaften zu
tun.
Um es noch einmal deutlich zu machen: Lediglich
17 Prozent der gesamten Masse des Weltraumes
bestehen wohl aus sogenannter baryonischer
Materie.
Damit ist die gewöhnliche sichtbare Materie
gemeint.
Der überwiegende Rest ist noch unbekannt
und wird somit eben oft als Dunkle Materie
bezeichnet.
Um diese ungelösten Fragen der Kosmologie
endlich zu beantworten, suchen Forschungsteams
weltweit nach allen möglichen Teilchen, die
theoretisch existieren könnten.
Immer auf der Spur nach den ultimativen Bausteinen
des Kosmos.
Mit Hilfe von Teilchenbeschleunigern wird
Materie immer weiter in immer kleinere Partikel
zerlegt.
Die große Hoffnung: Zusammengesetzt könnten
diese vielen Mosaik-Stückchen irgendwann
ein Gesamtbild vom Universum; zu seiner Entstehung
und Zusammensetzung liefern.
In diesem Zusammenhang hat ein japanisches
Forschungsteam jetzt einen Erfolg verbucht.
Die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
nutzten dazu Teilchenbeschleuniger am Forschungskomplex
J-Parc, etwa 120 Kilometer nördlich von Tokio
entfernt.
Am “Japan Proton Accelerator Research Complex
werden Protonen derzeit auf 30 Gigaelektronenvolt
beschleunigt.
Konkret ging es um ein sehr exotisches Teilchen,
das sogenannte Anti-Kaon.
Kurz zur Erklärung: Kaonen sind mittelschwere,
subatomare Teilchen, die sich aus zwei Quarks
zusammensetzen, genau genommen aus einem Quark-Antiquark-Paar.
Eigentlich findet man sie nur in Teilchenbeschleunigern
und in kleiner Anzahl auch in der kosmischen
Strahlung.
Schon seit einiger Zeit geht die Fachwelt
davon aus, dass Kaonen eine bestimmte Wirkung
im Atomkern haben könnten.
Doch entsprechende Experimente zu dieser Annahme
lieferten keine eindeutigen Ergebnisse.
Bis jetzt!
Der aktuelle Erfolg gelang dem japanischen
Forschungsteam, indem ein Neutron in einem
Helium-3-Isotop durch ein Anti-Kaon ersetzt
wurde.
Denn so gelang es tatsächlich, eine stabile
Form neuer Materie zu kreieren.
Bei dem Experiment wurde das Helium-3-Isotop
mit hochenenergetischen Anti-Kaonen beschossen.
Wird bei diesem Bombardement ein Neutron exakt
getroffen, wird es aus dem Kern des Atoms
herausgeschlagen und das Anti-Kaon nimmt seinen
Platz ein.
Eigentlich sollten die beiden Protonen, die
somit nicht mehr aneinander gebunden sind,
auseinanderfliegen.
Doch das Anti-Kaon verhinderte dies, da es
selbst mit den beiden Protonen eine stabile
Einheit bildet.
Dieser neu gebildete Kerncluster war sogar
für das Forschungsteam selbst eine große
Überraschung: “Wie das Neutron, hält das
exotische Teilchen die beiden Protonen zusammen
und generiert einen gebundenen Zustand”.
Wirklich erstaunlich sei dabei, dass das Anti-Kaon
dabei im Kern als eigenständiger Baustein
existiert.
Dies sorge nicht nur dafür, dass der Atomkern
stabiler ist als bislang angenommen, sondern
auch für eine enorme Bindungsenergie, so
die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler.
Auch, wenn der neu entstandene Kerncluster
nicht wirklich lange stabil ist, konnte also
seine extrem hohe Bindungsenergie gemessen
werden.
Diese Erkennntisse ermöglichen es den Fachleuten
also, Kernmaterie mit hoher Dichte zu erzeugen
und diese bei annähernd Normaltemperaturen
weiter zu untersuchen.
Ein vielleicht erster Schritt, um beispielsweise
den Aufbau massereicher Neutronensterne zu
verstehen.
Und ich finde es schon absolut bahnbrechend,
dass hier wirklich eine neue Art der Materie
ja, quasi “entwickelt” wurde und das tatsächlich
möglich ist.
Das könnte der Suche nach der Dunklen Materie
vollkommen neue Perspektiven öffnen.
Dunkle Materie - die Suche nach dem Unsichtbaren.
Noch mehr zu diesem Thema findet ihr hier,
wenn ihr auf dieses Video klickt bei Dr.
Whatson - unbedingt draufklicken, ansehen
und abonnieren.
Ansonsten bis dann, bleibt dran.